zornig bist du schneller als jedes
fahrzeug oder flugzeug gehirn geht auf
urlaub wirklich gern bucht auf trivago
jetzt gerade
es gibt so tage an denen man einfach nur
zweifeln kann ein solcher tag ist heute
für mich denn ich habe heute eine sache
gesehen die mich noch ein ganzes
stückchen weiter vom glauben ab gebracht
hat als ich sowieso schon war und zwar
leute die detektive unter euch werden
mit sicherheit schon bemerkt haben dass
dieses video ein erneutes video über die
deutsche youtube
rebecca ist jetzt fragt ihr euch
vielleicht sebastian warum ich schon
wieder ein video bekkering die antwort
ist leute dass ich mir tatsächlich auch
selbst gedacht habe
muss das sein muss ich noch mal ein
video encoding machen aber ich habe mich
letzten endes dazu entschieden ja ich
werde das machen weil es zwei
veränderungen gab die erste veränderung
ist dass ich ja einen englischen kanal
gefunden habe von dem rebecca ring
höchstwahrscheinlich einen großteil
ihrer videos einfach straight cloud okay
das wollte ich euch zeigen und
vielleicht noch mal zwei ist dass sie
gestern ein video hochgeladen hat wo man
sich wirklich nur noch an den kopf
fassen kann
es ist einfach so also sie hat ja immer
so rufen niemals und 83 oder sowas oder
foxtrott story an videos gemacht aber
jetzt finde ich den bogen überspannt und
zwar hat sie jetzt in ihre seltsame drei
uhr nachts masche sonic reingezogen
sonic möchte von allen guten geistern
verlassen bei sonic ist für mich auch
wirklich eine grenze überschritten hat
sonic tatsächlich ein videospiel
karrierist denen ich auch mit meiner
eigenen jugend verbinde
und da liegt für mich wirklich die linie
wo ich sage als stopp das ist meine
haushalt wir machen denn so aber ich
will sagen bevor wenn es wie bereits
schon heute möchte ich mit der ersten
sache die ich angesprochen habe nicht
länger auf die folter spannen und zwar
habe ich einen englischen kanal gefunden
mit namen plassniks so und jetzt gucken
wir mal und vergleichbare rebecca wings
videos und fand nichts mit denen von
phoenix alles klar
rebecca hat gestern hochgeladen schreibe
um drei uhr nachts niemals mit sonic auf
roddicks wohl auch so ein video
hochgeladen hat vielleicht vorher wir
geben ein sonic und wir finden in dieser
pressemeldung sind auch schon ein paar
videos mit sonic gemacht und zwar
dieselbe art wie wedding sie macht
nämlich drei uhr nachts videos zb das
hier in dem er drei uhr nachts charlie
charlie mit 20 spielt oder wie wir es
hier mit auch hier ruft der 83 an beide
videos deutlich vor rebecca hochgeladen
machen wir weiter
rebecca wien hat vor einer woche
hochgeladen spiel um drei uhr nachts
niemals charlie charlie mit elsa aus
posen zwei vor zwei monaten bei plasma
nix zu not play charlie charlie ist ja
eigentlich genau das gleiche video und
schauen ob das thumbnail hier ist es von
the calling hier ist das von plassniks
sind schon gewisse ähnlichkeiten da
bestimmt und zufall oder machen wir
weiter
waging hat vor einem monat hochgeladen
facetime um drei uhr nachts niemals mit
dem grinch an weihnachten zumindest das
heute zumindest das wird doch nicht von
plasmon links geklaut sein oder kann er
nicht sein auch dazu viele videos auf
dem kanal komplex zum beispiel hier vor
über einem jahr schon do not facetime
begrenzt
was genau das gleiche video ist schreib
mir gerne mal die kommentare was ihr
davon haltet für mich sieht das ganze so
aus als würde rebecca wegen nicht nur
sehr sehr sehr seltsam auch und gerade
raus absurde videos machen so hat doch
noch den großteil davon klauen
na ja wunderbar was geht da mit einer
neuen und weiteren drei uhr nachts
challenge und es geht wieder um eine
verfluchte nummer
harry irgendwie verpasst es immer so
plastics auch in schortens zu geben oder
so einfach so jo diese video.de habe ich
übrigens von dem englischen youtube live
mix der macht aufstellen wie es in die
richtung und da lasse ich mich gerne mal
inspirieren
das irgendwie finde ich das nicht den
videos manchmal vergisst dass ihr das
mal oder mach dir das mit absicht also
das hat dazu stand darf ich dazu
gefunden habe war so seltsam
deswegen war ich mir anfangs nicht so
sicher soll ich die überhaupt
anschreiben deswegen habe ich erst mal
sein lassen aber doch nicht so ein
unsinn rebecca ich gehe jetzt in diesem
video einfach mal davon aus dass meine
theorie mit plasma nix das ewig videos
von dem cloud war es okay alles klar
dann so was zu erzählen wie ja ich habe
von dieser nummer gehört und ich weiß
nicht wie ich die anrufer soll alter ich
weiß von dieser nummer nicht gehört du
hast dieses video eins zu eins bei einem
englischsprachigen youtuber gesehen und
übernimmst das jetzt dann auch noch sich
so ein unsinn daher zu fantasieren die
geeignet ich dachte mir okay
wagen wir es einfach mal weil ihr wurde
wach angezeigt auf jeden fall falls sich
jetzt fragt ja ich frage mich ich frage
mich tatsächlich was ich habe mich bei
dir wurde was angezeigt kann es
möglicherweise sein dass der youtuber
plassniks die angezeigt wurde
und das tut sich da also ein bisschen
ein bisschen inspiriert was inspiriert
was ja ich habe eine verfluchte nummer
gefunden
aber darunter stand auf gar keinen fall
anschreiben mit tausenden ausrufezeichen
wirklich leute also ich muss sagen da da
da sterben dann wirklich die
gehirnzellen haben das waren ich jetzt
gerade nicht mal so in diesem spaß und
ich sonst immer sagen sondern will mein
gehirn wirklich urlaub wenn ich sowas
sehr egal
sorry aber also das war schon schlimm
genug oder an absurd genug diese videos
sich anzuschauen und für sie diese
videos zu machen als es nur darum ging
dass sie mit drei uhr nachts mit elsa
telefoniert oder so aber diese
dimensionen dass dies wie es halt
einfach auch noch höchst wahrscheinlich
geklaut sind das macht das ganze das ist
jetzt mal auf ein anderes level aber
darunter stand auf gar keinen fall
anschreiben mit tausenden ausrufezeichen
wo ich dachte mir okay das habe ich
irgendwie noch nie so wirklich gelesen
ja die sich selbst so also okay okay
also sie hat noch nie gelesen rufe diese
nummer niemals an rebecca wo steht dein
kopf wirklich
wirklich wirklich wirklich wo steht dein
kopf jedes zweite video gefühlt von dir
heißt face time um drei uhr nachts nicht
mit elster spiele um drei uhr nachts
nicht charlie charlie mit meinem linken
fuß
jedes zweite video von dir heißt mache
das nicht okay und jetzt sagt mir dass
du dir jetzt sagst mir dass die
aufforderung das nicht zu machen für
dich etwas neues ist waren schon die
meisten verfluchten nummern aber ich
habe noch nie so eine nachricht bewusste
ausdrücklich darunter standgerät
deswegen weil ein bisschen skeptisch
in dem fall ist etwas ganz besonderes
wahrscheinlich hat diese person diese
ace ich kann diesen job mit machen keine
person hat ihr diese nummer gegeben
keine person hat unter dieser nummer
darunter geschrieben und bitte nicht
anrufen alter das gibt es alles will ich
das ist alles ausgedacht was für ein
fantasie universum ist das alles ist
ausgedacht hat gesagt ich habe mir aber
die nummer auf dem zettel aufgeschrieben
oder habe ich mein geschickt und mir
wurde tatsächlich ein bild angezeigt und
ein status das krasseste finde ich ist
so dass das das also so halt so wedding
soll wahrscheinlich so einer der die
haut in der trainerin für so die junge
mädels in deutschland ist so legal und
die blicke hinter die kulissen
also die jungen kids die den checken
dass hier einfach nicht die denke ich oh
ngbk ihm ein idol und das ist das größte
für mich so die pein ja nicht was da
hinter den kulissen abgeht wie peinlich
dass das alles komplett ausgedacht ist
und zwar richtig so seltsame und man
könnte schon fast mein verwirrter art
und weise und das höchstwahrscheinlich
auch noch der großteil einfach geklaut
ist also ich will auch nicht für tv
hüttenberg reden aber wie viele vorlagen
gibt diese frau mir ich weiß nicht ob
das ein scherz war aber können wir diese
eine dieser geste noch haben das
beschreibt
ziemlich meine reaktion auf diese videos
aber ohne mit sollte ich will nicht dass
da so so charaktere aus meiner jugend
reingezogen haben wird ja okay also
vielleicht stelle ich an der stelle
schon mal eine kleine liste auch okay
rebecca also ich werde dir sehr
verbunden wenn du folgende charaktere
nicht einbauen wird ist mario und jedem
charakter aus dem mario universum sonic
auch nicht kein charakter aus assassin's
creed kein charakter aus der gta serie
raymond ist verboten und auch sonst mach
einfach nicht so hat das ist einfach mit
dem daumen nach oben wissen ob ihr tonic
seit ob ihr sonicmic ich finde ich
eigentlich ganz cool ich bin teamplayer
sonics deswegen diesem video war es
leichter ich habe jetzt mein notebook
eben geöffnet nicht dass ich eben eine
kacke lava und darf ich kurz wissen
gebraucht nicht nicht leute nicht dass
eine katze ja okay dass in diesem video
sind knallharte fakten knallharte
gefundene verfluchte nummern keine
videos sind von englischen team an
geklaut okay
deswegen ist erlebte worden
ich hab keinen bock mehr auf den boden
und dann beginnt die ganze prozedur
wirklich schema f wie jedes andere drei
uhr nachts video erst erstmal um 40.000
likes bitten ja dann zeigt sie irgendwie
das whatsapp bild so die macht es auch
immer gleich alter dann zeigt sie das
wort apple danach schreibt sie hallo bis
zu sonnig bleiben
es ist wirklich immer schema f also ich
weiß ja aus moneygall aus einem
videospiel antwortet ja ich bin zwar
nicht wieso schreibst du mir gehirn geht
auf urlaub wirklich gern gebucht auf
trivago jetzt gerade das war komisch
geburtstag ich weiß aber gar nicht
negativ also ich nicht ich es wirklich
nicht ich das nicht wie kann ein mensch
das anschauen auch wenn dieser mensch
acht jahre alt ist und nicht besonders
hell wie kann er sich das anschauen und
sich denken
ja das ist sonnig rebecca schreibt dem
nur so ich hab da eine nummer aus dem
hinterhalt passte sie veröffentlicht und
sonnig ein igel mit blauen haaren oder
stacheln antwortet nein wieso sollte ich
wer war das egal wem können da nicht die
letzten synapsen im hirn wegfallen wenn
man sowas sieht wie gesagt hat ich habe
mir auch mal ein speziell zu dem thema
video clown und die kommentare hier
kriegt einen völlig vorstellungsvideo
hier um könnte mein klavier und ich bin
der strauß macht's gut und nicht
besorgen